I want to give you a great formula for
Respiratory Health whether you have
mucus or you're over incoming some type
of immune response this is what I
consider the perfect formula for
supporting your lungs now of course
check with your doctor before
implementing any of my suggestions this
is not meant to replace your medical
care this is just meant to give you a
good potential solution to help you pull
yourself out of a long situation and
help you breathe because breathing is a
good thing nowadays all right what
you're going to need is you're going to
need a nebulizer what's a nebulizer well
it's a little device that can turn
liquid into a Mist so you can inhale the
material that you're trying to use to
help remedy your lung situation so
you're going to use this nebulizer twice
a day okay now this is what you're going
to put in the nebulizer
it's all based around one cup of water
so the first thing you're going to add
is about a fourth of a teaspoon of sea
salt I like Himalayan sea salt but you
can use any of the good high quality sea
salts and so the first thing you do is
you're going to dissolve it in the water
so that's step one now salt water is
great for breaking up mucus helping you
breathe better just like if you're at
the ocean you're just going to naturally
breathe better so there's a lot of great
properties in sea salt it's it's you
know to some degree it's like a
probiotic because there are friendly
microbes in the salt and there's not a
lot of pathogens that actually live and
thrive in sea salt so sea salt is
antimicrobial all right the next thing
you're going to put into this concoction
is one drop of garlic oil okay white
garlic oil
garlic oil is probably one of the most
potent antimicrobial potent
anti-pathogenic remedies that I know
about and so if there's anything
unfriendly living in your sinuses or in
your lungs garlic is going to make it
very very hard for those pathogens to
exist especially in the virus family now
the next remedy that I'm going to
recommend is one drop of black seed oil
the remedy black seed has been around
for a very very long time like thousands
of years one of the things that I like
about it it's great for your lungs it's
a bronchodilator so it can actually open
up your lungs and allow you to breathe
better it's also a very very potent
anti-microbial it's a very very potent
anti-inflammatory all right the next
part of this remedy is you're going to
get some povidone iodine another name
for that would be Betadine but you're
going to use two drops of this iodine
okay add two drops iodine is a known
remedy for supporting everything
respiratory as well as everything
microbial so iodine makes it very
difficult for these pathogens to survive
so iodine is a really good remedy for
supporting healthy lungs and I will put
some interesting research in the
description down below that you
definitely want to study
so you're not just taking my word for it
now the last thing I want to recommend
um
it's optional I do recommend it but
colloidal silver has been around for 125
years at least I think it was 1938 it
was even used as a natural antibiotic so
colloidal silver is um these suspended
particles of silver in a solution and
it's a great remedy for so many things I
used to give my kids I used to take it
myself you can put it in Neti Pot you
can just put it in your mouth you can
even put it in your eye if there's an
infection so it's it's quite safe and
it's quite effective
so I would use five drops of colloidal
silver so just mix all this stuff up and
do your nebulizer experience twice a day
and start to breathe again so you can
sleep better and you can function and
break up some of this mucus that tends
to be lodged in your respiratory tract
now if you haven't seen my video on sea
salt in your lungs I put that right here
check it out